knowing that you love these sort of
characters with edges
how do you make them still redeemable
likable in some way maybe they're not
even likeable but somehow that the
audience
is not going to give up on them because
they're humans
they're just like you and me that's the
point is like if you can just
get the point across that like these
people all they all sleep they all eat
you know they all breathe oxygen like if
you can just get that little point
across
i think we all relate to them it's so
silly but i've always
thought about because i do like these
characters that are a little off that
are a little
um you know sometimes make
it make the make the bad decision
instead of the good decision
but i think if you also show them as
they're humans they struggle with so
many of the same things we do they
struggle with
how they're going to pay their rent they
struggle with did the parents love them
they struggle with all these very human
factors
if you can just show them a little of
that i think we
we can't help but relate to them um
and that's you know so i try to show
maybe people
also you know small details
in their personal life you know show a
lot of this new movie
it's a guy sitting by himself in a room
eating and watching tv
because we all sit in a room and eat you
know we all
sometimes sit by ourselves and watch you
we all have trouble sleeping you know we
all have nightmares like we
these little things so i think that's
how you you just humanize them through
reality
um and also you know and i think even in
a more surreal movie you kind of take
that approach where you
you know you show that there's asserted
humanity
behind the bad decision-making you know
behind the kind of like acting and bad
faith
type of uh decisions so that's it for me
it's just like you know if you can just
just get the point just just for a
moment across
you can get away with whatever you want
you know we we there's a lot of
irreprehensible characters in cinema
that i love bad lieutenant right
oh yeah bad lieutenant's taco harvey
keitel is the great example of it
but in and also
you know in that film but he tries to
at one point he really feels like he's
making the right decision
and you have to show that you know you
show the human side
to the character and i think we all will
be willing to go for the ride if it's
also entertaining
you know that's a big part of it as well
yeah and i'd love to see more female
characters like that because it
you know uh margaret atwood has a great
quote and she said that
you know women are either painted as
either just total angels or just
horrible human beings but they're human
and so there's a there's a spectrum you
know whereas i think
it feels like sometimes men can have
more of a gray area but i wish they
would show
they don't have to have such clearly
defined roles of
you know either she's a bad character or
she's great but she can't be anything in
between
well that was my goal with queen i
wanted to literally take a character
that we were so accustomed with with
james bonds or robert mitchum's or
steve mcqueen's or any of these great
you know these male icons that we've had
throughout the years
and allow a woman to make those same
mistakes allow
her to to to be able to live in that
gray area that you're talking about that
was really my goal was to take
all these characters and say why not let
a woman be it and you know what
i've had you should have heard some of
the irreprehensible things i've seen
written on the
internet about her you know and that's
because people
don't it's unfamiliar because we are in
this world where
we're we're so obsessed with a man and
woman that you know women
are a lot of times relegated to these
like either they're like these
terrible evil you know the woman who's
the psycho crazy woman that destroys
everything
right um or she's the uh
you know angel love interest savior
character and there ain't no difference
we all
we're all trying to figure this life
thing out together like why can't a
woman make the same decisions that a man
makes you know it's
crazy that that media has
sold us this lie for so long so yeah so
that queen
like a hundred percent and i i hope i
think i landed there i'm not sure if i
did
but i tried to let her live in this
morally gray area
and you know see i would
see how it goes and these were comments
underneath the trailer or
oh just in different comments in the
trailer
things i've heard people say to my face
things were people
you know the friends that that just
didn't even realize they were kind of
saying something that was you know it's
beyond not misogynistic it's just
unaware of of what they were saying
about a character
she's so hard you know yeah she's like
she's such a
right i go really because like if james
bond did that you wouldn't say that
you know if if if um
you know when ryan gosling punches uh
uh just like the one actress in the face
and drive no one ever asked about it
no one ever said you know but when
if she does it you know if she slaps
another person
suddenly she's like evil sometimes she's
cringe-worthy
and uh yeah no we got a lot you know
we've gotten a lot of great reviews but
we had a few people that really like
one of the misogynistic terrain on the
film interesting
yeah and good that's what i wanted
i want them to show their face yeah show
your face that's what you think say it
you know yeah that's conversation so
then there again you can't control the
outcome of the film and it's
it's it lands where it lands you know
yeah
you